[Music]  hi hello what's your name Melissa via  Senor and what do you do for a living  well I work at a retail store  and you happy about that not really no  and what do you want to do for a living  comedy I want to be a comedian an  impressionist  well good luck let's see what you got  all right here we go  this is Barbara Walters and today on my  show I have award-winning actress  Natalie Portman Natalie I hear you're  having a baby  I am Barbara  we're thinking of naming the baby oscar  but it's that that's silly because  that's my cat's name so  hey all it's Molly Cyrus what's up  what Dad no I'm not gonna clean my room  right now  want me to clean out your bank account  here yeah okay so here's the deal  okay so the celebrity I really hate  right now is Christina Aguilera yeah  because she totally messed up the Star  Spangled Banner am I right  oh say hey can you see  oh  [Applause]  [Music]